okay this one I'm gonna keep really
quick I just want to say a couple of
words about the casting of Jesse
Eisenberg as Lex Luthor I am gonna be
talking about Man of Steel with some
spoiler points but let's just get right
into it there's been a lot of confusion
surprised maybe even an outrage
obviously a lot of people were talking
Bryan Cranston who would be a very
awesome but also kind of obvious choice
for the part this is a more unusual one
so I'm going to talk about the areas
where it makes sense in the areas where
it's a little bit more questionable a
little bit of context first though I did
finally get her on seeing Man of Steel
they did what I had talked about before
that I hope they would do in terms of
how a darker grittier Superman would
work for the most part what they did was
gritty up the world and the setting
around him the character himself was
kept fairly stalwart yes he did end up
killing Zod which seems a little bit out
of character for him but I felt that
that move was earned and it still made
sense within the character as he was
presented was it a perfect movie
well no but as someone who enjoys
Superman but is fully open to new
interpretations I liked it and thought
for the most part it was successful in
what it said are doing perfect no but
definitely interesting and the casting
of Jesse Eisenberg is in that same mold
it's an interesting choice and here's
the area where where we know he can pull
this off there are a few things that Lex
Luthor as we're used to seeing him needs
to convey one of them is intelligence
Jesse Eisenberg can portray intelligence
that's basically why he got nominated
for an Oscar when he played Mark
Zuckerberg he could really convey the
raw intelligence of a character now
there's a few other things that he
doesn't have for at least we've never
seen him have before we are used to
seeing Lex Luthor with an inherent sense
of menace and intimidation so that seems
like a little bit of a stretch in
addition to that his age is a little bit
of a problem he's about 30 years old but
there's a few problems the first is the
perception of him is rather younger than
that kazi's had a tendency to play
characters younger than he really is for
quite a few years now so the public
perception of how old he is is a little
bit out of whack with his actual age
that's the first thing
but even if we buy him as being 30 years
old that seems a little bit young for
what were used to Lex Luthor being Lex
Luthor is not only a brilliant scientist
but he's also a tycoon he basically runs
metropolis and for a 30-year old to have
that degree of power seems a bit of a
stretch now that said
I'm saying all these things in the
context of how we are used to Lex Luthor
being portrayed there could have already
been changes to the character of the
writing that make Jesse Eisenberg make
more sense and fit as a character and
I'll be interested to see if that's the
case or if you can actually stretch his
acting chops enough to give us something
closer to the Lex Luthor that we are
used to seeing they're making choices
that may not always work and are clearly
upsetting the purists but they're
definitely interesting choices and
they're bold choices and I applaud them
for that and a lot of people's mind this
is the second bit of questionable
casting after Ben Affleck I don't see
where Ben Affleck was a problem people
have been holding daredevil against him
for way too long
given his output lately just let it go
it does seem a little bit like they're
overloading this movie and that worries
me slightly we've got Superman we've got
Batman they've cast a Wonder Woman
there's gotten Batman's gonna be in and
enough that we're gonna have Alfred
and now we've got Lex Luthor I am
getting a little bit worried about just
sheer overload but again it one thing
it's not going to be is uninteresting
and on that basis alone I will be there
to see how they pull it off if they pull
it off hope you will do and until next
time Council is adjourned